you are now in the world of Marvel right
this is a real question for you uh a lot
of people
have said the world of Marvel is amazing
until you're in it and you can't get out
of it
they say it's amazing until you're in
this machine and when you're in this
machine the machine doesn't want to let
you out it does not want to let you out
that's a better statement I don't think
you're trapped okay because we know you
could you could always go like a mouth
okay
but yeah you're it's it's kind of the
mafia sometimes too where they're like
uh you've been activated and we need you
here in November you're like oh but I
was doing anything they're like yeah you
was doing anything see you in November
what was the longest what was your
longest shoot
over over five months Jesus
not at home and no back and forth at the
time yeah a lot of backups too many back
and forth you know what I mean so it's
like you're really trying to go am I
just gonna go move here like be here for
this time and just figure out how to
live here during this down time you know
I
pets and I got you know my family's here
I got a real life yeah there's a lot of
things going on at home so that's not
always to me that's sort of the golden
noose of it all and that's the blessing
and the curse of it all because we're
very fortunate obviously to be able to
create these opportunities for ourselves
and for our kids and
be in a position for the first time in
my family probably in your family to
have a shot at whatever this
generational wealth things means and
have annuities and put things aside so
that you know when we're not here you
people are taken care of and hopefully
it lasts more than just one generation
um but at the same time like I said in
me you know I'm 56 years old damn
I'm sorry
I'm sorry because it was a thought no no
seriously it was a thought it was a
thought and I blurted it out
I'm fine okay but just understand I
didn't mean it the way it came out we'll
take a poll on how you meant it with
people here later after the show's over
but I can sit up here and honestly say
buddy that that was from a place of Love
got it
like damn you didn't if we could play it
back right now play it back these are
two different dams way back in slow
motion there wasn't no I said there was
no like wow I said damn no you said the
word damn
do you want me to tell you how you said
it I know how I said it down do you want
me to say it back to you how I think you
said it go ahead damn not not true fam
not true fam I said Kevin I said damn it
each time you said it now it's gotten
quieter and quieter I could barely hear
you that last time when you said it well
that means that you can barely hear the
truth so who has the problem here
what's the problem
maybe 56 minutes the way you Nadia
Coleman each things it just flipping oh
I don't know what you just straight
around the way I'm not academic [__] huh
uh-oh does he not know who that is the
way I'm not accommodation yeah he thinks
he's the only one that could not have
come and eat you
what are you talking about you don't
think I know what number coming these
kids well what is
you heard me okay yeah
56. let's get back to it yeah still here
still kicking still walking
knees are still working no noise
right right
these aren't real Kevin whoa I put these
on to appear smart we're going to cut
this part out
you might need I'm not going to let this
fly you might need some of these to
appear smart this part won't make the
interview because you're my friend
do you want to see if it makes you
appear smart they match your they match
your suit let's start next to this part
yeah because it's not going to make it
try these
look how smart you go God damn
what Professor Hart not a combinichi
good wow
could you do something for me yes sir
could you pick up your wine glass to do
that pick up a wine glass can a cherry
get popped in a picnic and I'm not a
combination come on now don't do this to
me because that's what you did
whoa
oh my God
I don't think I love a person more man I
think I love a person more
[Music]